my guests tonight are the cast and
director of glass which is the highly
anticipated sequel to the film's
unbreakable and split
please welcome Anya Taylor joy M night
Shyamalan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
overhype man you are hard here the
height the height man
[Applause]
who you have a lot of shyness to
overcome oh okay you're doing it you're
getting there this is the most this is
the biggest reaction we've heard from
any group that's come on so far
yeah yeah I would say half a minutes for
your hat right there we have so much to
talk about night if I can call you night
yeah please how great is said having the
name night people call you night I now
it's a my middle names no but it's
fantastic it's absolutely fantastic what
do I called me said you call him night
and I thought that's one of the coolest
things I've ever heard so in graduations
on that thank you tonight fans and cast
waiting 18 years 18 years for this film
I know you were getting pressure from
fans we were getting pressure from any
of the people that cast to make this
film happen uh yeah actually I would I
would run into these guys these two guys
occasionally like one time Sam I don't
know if you remember we went I would run
in him in LA and he would drive by and
his car would stop and then he'd roll
down the window and I Sam how are you
when we make that my sequel
[Applause]
you get plenty of work I don't know what
you're complaining not the work I want
all right so Bruce do you remember when
when Knight pitched you the idea for a
breakable when did he wouldn't he first
tell you about this idea no I loved I
love this guy
yeah he said he sent me the script he
didn't saw he didn't tell me anything
about it I said I'll do it
wait so it's clear you didn't read the
script I just thought it absolutely not
Naxos into a shredder and said I'm doing
it right
cosmoses
yes yes that's how we booked him on this
show I don't care who it is I'm going
Nina you got out here you were like that
guy all right night how does it feel to
see these characters back again you have
been visualizing this as I said for 18
years what was it like the first time
that you saw Bruce Sam back in their
roles as these characters yeah you know
it's kind of it was strangely emotional
I kind of I kind of make my life since I
was 20
making original stories everything you
know is new and this is the first time I
actually wrote something that is based
on characters from a different point in
my life and when these guys kids I don't
know I didn't actually tell you guys
this when you guys came for the costume
test and we were checking out your
outfits and their first time that I saw
them on camera you know it's mr. glass
and David Dunn after 18 years I mean I
was guy got emotional the entire crew
the guys these got some of these guys
you know we're really young they're
working and everybody got quiet the
cameraman took his eye off of the camera
it was just a you know a really moving
moment to see these to play these iconic
characters I was very emotional for me
you see Sam you have said you have said
that you owe it to Bruce that you were
in unbreakable is that true yeah I was
finishing a movie
I just finished a movie in Watsons ID
which is in Morocco and I went to
Casablanca to chill for a week I was in
the casino plans blackjack on one side
of the room and I heard a voice go Sam I
look around it's like that Bruce Wow
Bruce boom we get up he's like I just
met this kid I just did a movie for him
he's writing a movie for us right now
I'll call it he calls night on the phone
and tells him he's with me and I'm
writing one of your scenes right now
are you who are you who yeah oh right
the dude oh oh the dead people movie I
wanted to eat I'm still asking for a job
which turned out to be Bruce's job yeah
but oh you get a job the Bruce
yeah yeah and Bruce is like yeah but
we're gonna do this movie together okay
cool let's do it
that's great no your life is fantastic
you're just hanging out playing
blackjack Bruce Willis comes up to you
says let's do a movie together with M
night Shyamalan then the rest your life
whenever you see him walking down the
street you go make a MA and sequel
[Applause]
you